it's my second day in Asia where I'm
trying to help them more place
restaurant and golf club the foods stuck
in the 70s
as usual there are no customers today AM
is booked for lunch no nothing and
tonight no so we did have someone come
in to look at the restaurant it's either
here or tGI's I'd rather go to tGI's
mild Roberson the Executive Chef should
be tearing his hair out he's taking the
day off chickens but you look different
out your wives you look like a monk on
leave Thanks
I'm going to play golf later Oh is he
around don't play golf we're supposed to
be running an empty restaurant to get it
off the ground to get it moving towards
something semi decent golf course at
least he knows there's something wrong
because he's hired a new head chef now
there are three talked about too many
cooks one's a joke Frenchman the other
is stuck in the 70s I hope Andy trout
from the 21st century you've really got
your work cut out there and I and you
can't go in with all guns blazing
putting them all in the Ghoulies 24
hours you'll have no more left
I know I know how would you how would
you play this situation know as menu
down to him with yeah start off really
simple yeah and and look what's going on
locally Andy looks promising but I had
to show him what he's up against what is
that
Jesus arrived painful it's like a
dehydrate in silicon but actually it's a
microwave frozen deep-fried burger
what's that Caesar salad looks like a
plate of worms got it breaks my heart
want to see this show you know and his
watch some really good places he's gonna
need all these experience know it's
instantly so polished P sauce in a jar
and a French dress he's as shocked as I
am but will his ready-made packet food
lazy cooking and it's more expensive
than making it fresh you're being a
little [ __ ] again how can we have a
Frenchman here we're buying French
dressing
I mean press so far with Andy's he seems
keen to make changes and this and they
put it on the menu is Brussels pate
Brussels with chicken it's just plastic
crap yeah Andy could be the chef I been
looking for and that means I can get out
of the kitchen and work with the owners